Це секції знятих з експлуатації турбін
у вітровому парку на півночі Німеччини.
Місцеві екологи незадоволені тим,
що так багато фундаменту все ще лишається в землі.
Вони хочуть, щоб прибрали усе.
Бетонні основи можна подрібнити
та використовувати для будівництва доріг.
А от самі пропелери містять скло- та вуглецеві волокна,
тому просто спалити їх – не варіант.
Проблема в тому, що під час їхнього спалювання виділяються пил та токсичні гази.
Тобто позбутися їх необхідно, але це складно.
Адже пил забиває фільтри, а вуглецеві волокна
проводять струм, тому можуть зумовити короткі замикання
та загорання фільтрів. Тож підприємства зі спалення сміття
відмовляються або вимагають багато грошей за спалення.
Дуже багато з 30 тисяч турбін у Німеччині
будуть виведені з експлуатації у найближчі кілька років.
Їх замінять більшими і сучаснішими.
Нині на часі розробити екологічний метод
переробки старих вітряків, перш ніж їх масово почнуть зносити.
Німецька компанія Neocomp спеціалізується
на переробці сучасних складних матеріалів.
Діапазон їхнього застосування нині дуже широкий:
приміром, пластик зі вмістом скловолокон та вуглецевих волокон
можна знайти не лише у пропелерах вітряків, а й у літакобудуванні.
Однак що можна з ним вдіяти після завершення експлуатації?
Коли ви вже спекли пиріг, то у всьому світі не знайдеться такої техніки,
яка б дозволила вам відокремити яйця, соду, дріжджі та молоко.
Так само і з реактопластами,
тобто термореактивним пластмасами, про які йде мова.
Це склопластик і вуглепластик.
Ці матеріали настільки змішані, що їх не можливо розділити на складові.
Компанія розробила процедуру, яка допомагає вирішити проблему.
Матеріали подрібнюють.
Отримана тирса легка та зручна у використанні.
По-перше, її можна спалювати замість горючих
корисних копалин на виробництві цементу,
по-друге, її можна змішувати з рештками виробництва паперу
та перетворювати на гранулят.
А гранулят, у свою чергу, можна використовувати
як компонент цементу, замість піску.
Таким чином багато старих пропелерів можуть перетворитися на цемент
у фундаменті нового покоління вітрових турбін.